there are many ways of thinking about a
revolution I think one of the problems
with the 20th century was that at least
until the uprisings against communism in
the 1980s it it conflated revolution
with a social revolution a class
struggle which would redistribute
material things but that didn't pay
attention to as the importance of a
political revolution which is a
democratic revolution that mobilizes
across classes for the sake of creating
a more democratic or just a Democratic
Society and so definitely what's been
sweeping across the Arab world today in
the Middle East and particularly in
North Africa is a democratic revolution
and its most important parallel is what
happened in Eastern Europe in the ninth
in the late 1980s
I think that revolutions political
revolutions especially I think happen in
a kind of symbolic process of copying or
iteration that people under they see
something else happening and they think
that's possible for us they have a model
in terms of performance and symbolic
action in an inspiration and then they
they may be able to take that model
inside of itself so for example in the
American Revolution in the 1770s natives
was had a tremendous well over affected
help stimulate the French Revolution and
the French Revolution help stimulate
others had provided rhetoric and models
what's happening in the year what
happened in in the year 2011 is a
tremendous appropriation of the model of
democratic revolution by activists
secular and religious in the Middle East
first in Tunisia which just have its own
parliamentary elections yesterday and
the day before and especially in Egypt
which is the most important the largest
population the most influential country
and then the success of this people's
mobilization in Egypt not only spread
this model of a cross class people's
uprising to other Arabic countries and
was highly stimulating and energizing
but it seemed to spread throughout
Europe and the United States and I'm so
that if you look at Western Europe in
the United States you see that for three
years of budget cutting in economic
crisis there was no left-wing reaction
there was no liberal in our in our in
our pilots in the United States no
liberal uprising and
to the contrary Social Democrats and
liberals felt that they were resigned
they felt helpless and it was the
right-wing movements like the Tea Party
that seemed vitalized by by this whole
process but I think as a result of Egypt
and the of and the Arab Spring as it's
called there are actually more reactions
that began in in Spain in Madrid and
Barcelona earlier this year which then
had reverberations in in London and
peace protest I mean protests for
justice in Israel in earlier this year
there were big demonstrations and
occupations in Madison Wisconsin against
the proposed budget cuts by the Governor
of Wisconsin and finally about six six
weeks ago they began to be this Occupy
Wall Street movement which electrified
and set off new rounds of i would say
copying and replication throughout the
United States and and Europe and
elsewhere so I do think that this
process has been a very demonstrative
one very theatrical that the audience
for their performances has have turned
themselves into actress
yes no the social media allow a very
rapid I communication of anything that's
happening and it brings audiences well
outside of the immediate context into an
intense relationship with political
performances the fact that the Egypt
revolution had such widespread effect
throughout the Arab world and then have
these knock-on effects all over Europe
in the u.s. is partly the effect of the
social media during the revolution first
because the Facebook page we are all
kalid syed which the movement started
had was in english in arabic and there
were millions of people who followed the
english facebook which was 24 7 images
messages so the the impact of the social
media allowed global civil society to be
very much involved as fused spectators
with this movement and in that respect
the the technology of social media
definitely was a very unique factor in
this upheaval at the same time you don't
want to confuse the medium with the
message social media by themselves don't
create revolutions you need ideology you
need culture and you can't forget the
role of what I call carrier groups of
leadership and of intellectuals and of
cultural changes and in the Egyptian
case and the other Arab Spring cases
there had been at least a decade of
intellectual discussion of democracy
there been a change of Islam towards
much of this I'm embracing more moderate
more democratic ideas I in reaction
against Islam assessment and
terrorism and theocratic dictatorship
and rent so these cultural
transformations were what was carried by
the social media so it's the medium and
the message need to work together